um
favor
para mim
é bem Boa tarde pessoal é um prazer
estar aqui com todos vocês é eu acredito
que
deixa eu ver
assim ele já me apresentou o melhor do
que eu conseguiria bem
você e aqui nós temos com todos vocês o
senhor t-rex eu gosto muito de
apresentar isso porque algumas grandes
verdades elas Nós acreditamos que o
mundo ele tá como tá porque simplesmente
existem coisas que não acabam Mas as
coisas acabam se um grande Predador como
o t-rex e todos os dinossauros
desapareceram da face da terra sem
deixar poucos vestígios fósseis então
tudo que existe no mundo está aí para
ser mudado e a e a ideia que eu gostaria
de espalhar com vocês hoje nesse evento
Ted que tem esse propósito de inspirar
as pessoas a mudar é que nós podemos sim
construir um mundo melhor se nós
queremos um Se nós queremos construir o
que nós queremos na verdade muito pode
ser qualquer coisa que nós queiramos e
qualquer coisa que nós permitamos que
ele seja porque todo ser toda a pessoa
aqui ela é política seja por ação ou por
omissão quando nós deixamos de agir para
realizar uma ação no mundo nós também
estamos permitindo que algo aconteça o
mal não ocorre apenas pelo pelas pessoas
que pensam mal o mal também ocorre
porque os bons se isentam de evitá-lo e
nós podemos transformar o mundo em
qualquer coisa que nós criança e por
isso a minha maior mensagem para vocês
aí empreendendo não importa a idade eu
sou era do interior e deixei muitos anos
de nem saber o que significava a palavra
empreender e a partir que eu continuei
que eu comecei eu acredito que essa é a
forma perns e de se mudar o mundo e eu
acredito que cada um de vocês pode isso
quando a gente constrói um negócio a
gente está mudando um pedaço do mundo
pode ser pequeno pode ser algumas
pessoas Você pode você realizar um
produto e colocar para as pessoas usá-lo
você tá mudando O entorno delas e as
relações sociais entre elas e dá para
fazer isso com poucos recursos e com
poucos recursos eu quero dizer que você
pode fazer isso com poucas pessoas com
pouco dinheiro e às vezes até mesmo um
pouco tempo e eu vou compartilhar com
vocês as coisas que eu acreditei que eu
acredito que me levaram a empreender
melhor e que podem abrir a cabeça de
cada um de vocês para empreender também
bem Tem uma frase muito clássica que
está se tornando um jargão que é o
software está comendo o mundo e essa é
uma grande verdade grande parte das
nossas relações e de formas de interagir
no mundo elas estão sendo alterado
drasticamente por software e
basicamente Algumas pessoas tentam
substituir as relações humanas por
software Mas eu sou um grande partidário
de que nós devemos estender o ser humano
com softwares estender as nossas
relações
é um grande cientista brasileiro que é o
Miguel nicolelis que ele traz eu a
teoria do cérebro relativístico que ele
mostra que o nosso cérebro ele tá sempre
uma piada realidade e aquilo que nós
utilizamos como ferramenta se torna a
parte dele é é assim ela tem amplas
consequências para quem trabalha com os
habilidade interface como eu no meu dia
a dia mas também tem implicações para
cada um de vocês porque tudo aquilo que
você tá usando você tá tornando aquilo
uma parte de você quer você perceba quer
não é programa eu seja programado eu não
sei quantos de vocês têm interesse em
programar mas eu falo para todo mundo
aprender pelo menos uma linguagem de
script mais fácil é porque
os algoritmos e todos os softwares eles
estão sendo criados e software lei
quando algo se coloca para você e você
não sabe como ele funciona você escravo
das relações sociais e políticas que
aquele software tá trazendo até você a
ré passa coisa que não escalo no começo
de um negócio você precisa fazer muita
coisa que não vai ter software para
aquilo Na real você só vai criar coisas
interessantes quando você saber tão bem
aquela coisa fazendo as coisas na mão
mesmo que quando você quer o seu
software você não vai ter perdido tempo
criando um software desnecessário e faça
coisa que as pessoas queiram
descubra tem milhões de problemas no
mundo para se atacado tem milhões de
coisa que vocês amam e que outras
pessoas gostam também então crie coisas
que as outras pessoas também queiram é
aprenda a servir eu acho que essa é a
maior lição que eu tive empreendendo é
muitas pessoas começam a
empreendedorismo para não ter chefe mas
a verdade é que a partir do momento que
você começar a empreender você vai ter
centenas de chefes que são seus clientes
então é muito importante aprender a
servir EA entender seu negócio além do
câmpus o campus ele é uma e para as
pessoas colocarem seus negócios em uma
pequena folha então
se vocês forem emergir no
empreendedorismo alguém vai apresentar o
Canvas do modelo de negócio para vocês
mas por favor valem deles muitas vezes
as pessoas confundem ferramentas com
com a coisa-em-si e ficam fazendo apenas
masturbação Mental é sempre lá pelo
curso aqui são acho que é o maior agora
ensinamentos que as pessoas que eu posso
dar para qualquer pessoa é vejo o curso
para adquirir uma pessoa sempre é
startups no final igual crescimento é
quando você vai empreender e a forma
mais legal de fazer isso através de uma
Startup que é uma empresa pequena que
tem um alto crescimento é descobrir o
que vai fazer esse crescimento o que vai
levar você mais longe e nesse sentido eu
acredito que eles estavam um pouco como
a vida é um dos meus autores e se chama
Kevin Kelly ele foi um dos fundadores da
revista wired nos Estados Unidos e ele
tem um livro muito interessante que
chama o que a tecnologia quer ele ainda
não tem tradução português então é o a
tecnologia antes mas é um dos melhores
livros que eu já li pois ele mostra a
evolução da tecnologia como
uma forma inerente inexorável do
universo de criar novas coisas e eu
acredito que muita das nossas relações
nos Empreendimentos em si são regidos
por essas mesmas forças e essas forças
nos diz que além Kelly são as mesmas
forças da vida e ele e ele compartilha
com a gente aos 12 as 12 características
da vida que eu acredito que se não for
importante para o empreendimento é
importante para cada um de nós
entendemos que a eficiência nós temos
que ser eficientes nas coisas que nós
realizamos fazer mais com menos Mas
precisamos procurar oportunidades
descobrir coisas que estão Quebradas no
mundo e consertá-las e não é apenas
negócios é eu pegar o papel que caiu na
rua é Tem tantas formas de ajudar que
muitas vezes parece que a gente está
simplesmente cego para elas emergência
que é um é um caráter de quando
elementos isolados tem um comportamento
não previsto é a com base apenas no
comportamento individual que eu creio
que eu vejo todos os dias ocorrendo nos
Empreendimentos é complexidade é por
mais que a simplicidade seja buscado em
todas as coisas que nós fazemos é apenas
a complexidade que emergem alguns
padrões interessantes diversidade Então
nada de ter apenas uma opinião é sempre
buscar uma pluralidade de opiniões e
caminhos é ter uma frase do Benjamin
Franklin que eu acho muito boa que se um
negócio duas pessoas têm a mesma ideia é
uma delas é desnecessário e eu acredito
que isso vai muito de encontrar isso
especialização não dá para agradar a tua
a todos o tempo todo e também se você
escolher um caminho a seguir é o bico
idade a vida ela quer tá em todos os
lugares eu acredito que todas as pessoas
querem que as boas ações dela também
sejam compartilhados e estejam todos os
lugares então buscar essa peça e
compartilhamento em todos os lugares e
liberdade também um outro parâmetro que
a vida sempre Busca Ela sempre busca se
tornar independente dos padrões e buscar
novas formas de provocar esse Impacto
que nós queremos no mundo né e
mutualismo né Por incrível que pareça a
vida ela não existe Sem ela ter até
entre assim triste com a relação da
concorrência né 11 assim então os
predadores e os e as suas isso é o
alimento eles fazem parte de uma
intrincada relação em que todos são
necessários no ecossistema e da mesma
forma nós temos que estimular aquelas e
tem ideias contrárias à nossa isso é a
verdadeira liberdade e a verdadeira
democracia e não apenas a tentativa
destrutiva de eliminar os outros e
beleza né a vida ela busca a vida e vida
e beleza não é apenas é aquela coisa
estética do Prazer puro por si mesmo
beleza é criar coisas que se sustentem é
criar um código interessante é fazer uma
relação que você sente orgulho
a eficiência né a vida ela parece buscar
formas de ter uma consciência de si
mesma e é muito importante cada um de
nós aceitarmos esse essa habilidade né e
estrutura né é a vida de todas as formas
ela ela busca uma estrutura e eu
acredito que
fazendo boas ações não é simplesmente
importante nós temos que criar uma
estrutura para que essa boa ação possa
ser perpetuado e outras pessoas possam
compartilhar o próprio Ted x que nós
estamos aqui hoje é um evento que buscou
uma estrutura para que as pessoas
pudessem compartilhar ainda mais suas
ideias eu acho que criar fóruns e formas
dessas boas ideias espalharem mais ainda
é o que realmente importa e fazer com
que isso evolua porque voltando lá no
t-rex lá do início um dos grandes
problemas que os dinossauros enfrentaram
e não se continua conseguiram evoluir é
que eles não foram simplesmente os que
consegui o melhor ambiente uma pequena
mudança no ambiente dele provocou a
extinção de todos todas as espécies que
em um momento é dominavam a vida no
planeta Terra e da mesma forma é Charles
Darwin nos dizia que a sobrevivência não
é do mais forte como erroneamente
espalhados pelas pessoas ela é do que se
adapta melhor e acredito que se adaptar
é a coisa mais importante para todos e
cair na real nós simplesmente vamos
conseguir empreender se a gente
ir para a realidade e apanhar muito
e é isso só se nós construiremos um
mundo que nós queremos que ele pode ser
simplesmente qualquer coisa que qualquer
um de nós queremos mas nós temos que
criá-lo bem essa é uma boa ideia que eu
queria compartilhar com vocês que
empreendam obrigado
E aí